immer wieder gibt es meldungen die die
zerstörung der erde durch einen fremden
planeten vorhersagen teilweise werden
diese meldung mit planet iks also dem
neunten planeten in verbindung gebracht
der dieses jahr aus der bahn gerät und
auf die erde zu fliegt dabei hat der
planet einen so ungünstig land und
winkel so dass er nicht entdeckt werden
kann
was ist an dieser these dran sind wir in
gefahr jetzt ein klick zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
wir haben hier schon öfter über den
neunten planeten berichtet und erst
kürzlich wie schwer zu entdecken ist und
auch zuschauer vom krieg so habe mich
schon gefragt was es mit der these auf
sich hat dass dieser neunte planet oder
ein anderer planet aus dem sonnensystem
mit der erde zusammenstoßen wird ich
habe mich daraufhin mit dieser these
beschäftigt und mir mal angesehen welche
veröffentlichungen es dazu gibt und ich
bin tatsächlich auf einiges gestoßen
immer wieder ist da zu lesen dass der
planet nibiru auf die erde stürzen und
sie zerstören wird das verbreitet
natürlich angst und schrecken und wenn
es so wäre oder auch nur die
wahrscheinlichkeit bestünde dann müsste
man ja dringend handeln laut berichten
würden dass die eliten der welt ja auch
tun und hätten sich schon entsprechende
bunker gebaut die sie im ernstfall
schützen würden und das irre sogar die
nasa beschäftigt sich mit dem planeten
die büro und einer möglichen kollision
weil auch hier ständig danach gefragt
wird laut nasa gibt es rund zwei
millionen webseiten die sich mit einer
möglichen kollision beschäftigen und
auch ein datum wird schon genannt es ist
der fünfte oktober 2017 das wird im buch
planet excel 2007 tine reimer genannt
die these von dieser kollision wird zum
ersten mal von nancy lieder 995
aufgestellt sie ist kontakte rinn und an
alien implantat in ihrem gehirn durch
das in der lage ist signale von
außerirdischen aus dem sternensystem
zeta red die kuh die zu empfangen
ermöglicht ihr den empfang dieser
botschaft david stellt in seinem buch
fest dass es immer mehr erdbeben stürme
und sonstige naturkatastrophen gibt er
bekommt dabei unterstützung von
unternehmer robert vicino der weiß
nämlich mehr über die vorbereitungen der
eliten auf der welt er sagt der daily
mail zitat sie müssen sich selbst fragen
warum hat russland gerade mit 40
millionen menschen den ernstfall geprobt
es gibt keinen zweifel daran dass das
ende kommt es wird episch seien direkt
aus der bibel so leute jetzt kann ich
echt liebe ernst bleiben es gibt keine
ich zähle nochmal nach keine
wissenschaftliche veröffentlichung zu
einem planeten der mit der erde zusammen
stift und bitte jedes implantat trucks
noch allein schon dass die ankündigungen
dieser katastrophe dieses jahr jubiläum
feiert nibiru sollten bereits 2003 2012
im september 2015 verschoben auf den
dezember 2005
sind dann im september 2016 und jetzt
also im oktober 2017 mit der erde
kollidieren und der unternehmer robert
vicino stellt schutzbunker herum will
sie verkaufen
da ist ihm jedes mittel recht und der
ein oder andere superreiche verrückte
wird eben vielleicht glauben und ich
kann nur sagen hey das ist sämtliches
quatsch mit soße
jeder kann es selbst wissenschaftlich
überprüfen wir hatten sie ein video mit
niedrigstpreisen wissenschaft ist eine
tolle methode die sich seit tausenden
jahren immer wieder bewährt hat sie ist
super einfach und leicht zu verstehen
und jeder also auch ihr könnt es checken
was braucht es also für eine
wissenschaftliche erkenntnis punkt eins
jemand stellt eine these auf er oder sie
hat gelernt mit wissenschaftlichen
methoden umzugehen und kennt sich in dem
fachgebiet aus beim planeten wäre das
zum beispiel eine astrophysikerin oder
ein astrophysiker sie oder er hat zum
beispiel etwas beobachtet am besten
werden weitere belege für die
beobachtung gesammelt wurde zum beispiel
ein planet beobachtet dann wird nach
weiteren beweisen gesucht zum beispiel
nach veränderten umlaufbahn die daten
von teleskopen werden durchsucht und so
weiter das wird dann veröffentlicht
punkt 2 dann versucht jemand diese these
zu widerlegen oder zu bestätigen er
wendet dafür weitere methoden zur
überprüfung an sammelt weitere daten und
noten und nur dann wenn das geschehen
ist und die these mit einer gegenprobe
in frage gestellt und dann bestätigt
wurde ist es eine wissenschaftliche
erkenntnis vorher ist es eine hypothese
selbst die oder der wissenschaftler der
sie aufgestellt hat würde nie etwas
anderes behaupten
wie sieht es also bei libro aus da haben
wir schon das problem mit punkt eins
eine kontakten mit einem implantat naja
das erfüllt er die bedingungen für eine
einweisung in die psychiatrie und das
meine ich ernst als dass sie eine gute
experte für exoplaneten abgeben würde
aber es gibt noch einen weiteren haken
bei punkt eins keine beweise
auch david nitro bild in seinem buch
herum und will etwas von verstärkten
erdbeben und stürmen und vom biblischen
beweisen
bei der these der erdbeben viel zum
beispiel die physikalischen grundlagen
dafür dass ein planet der ferne
der mars jupiter oder venus sein muss
ansonsten hätten wir sehen müssen solche
effekte hervorrufen kann
das entspricht zwar der romantischen
vorstellung oder unromantischen
vorstellungen eines weltuntergangs hat
aber mit der realität einfach nichts zu
tun und zu biblischen beweisen
da brauche ich aber nichts zu sagen
alles was die bibel mit beweisen zu tun
hat ist dass wissenschaftler darüber
erkenntnisse haben ob die darin
beschriebenen ereignisse oder personen
so oder anders existiert haben oder eben
nicht keine prophezeiung in dem buch ist
eingetreten oder hat sich auch nur
angekündigt warum auch es wird ja auch
keinen sinn machen dass ein angeblich
blutiger gott die welt vernichtet zwar
wird die erde irgendwann mal im
räderwerk des universums zermalmt aber
nicht 2017 und nicht durch nibiru
sondern durch die sonne und es ist noch
ein paar milliarden jahre hin
das ist bekannt und wissenschaftlich
bewiesen und vorher werden wir
vielleicht mal ab und zu von einem was
du ihnen getroffen diese gefahr ist
bekannt und real und wir wissen
allerdings überhaupt nicht wann und wo
es gibt also reale gefahren aber dafür
gibt es auch thesen die auch bestätigt
wurden wissenschaftlich und genau das
ist bei der nero geschichte nicht der
fall nicht nur die these ist höchst
fragwürdig weil sie auch durch rein gar
nichts wissenschaftlich belegt ist
es gibt auch keine wissenschaftliche
überprüfung und da macht es überhaupt
keinen sinn auch nur einen gedanken
daran zu verwenden da ist mir echt mein
gehirn zu schadet ja nach diesem check
kann ich nur sagen ein hirngespinst der
weltuntergang fällt mal wieder aus über
den nächsten weltuntergang halten euch
natürlich auf dem laufenden
dafür mir hier einfach ein abo aufs auge
drücken dann verpasst er kein video mehr
bei tags und fischen und vergesst nicht
mehr einen genau auf die glocke zu geben
hier geht es zu den meistgeklickten
videos von pixum für den
unwahrscheinlichen fall dass ihr noch
nicht abonnenten seit und schreibt mir
doch mal in die kommentare
welche verschwörungstheorien ich noch so
vorstellen soll und gerne auch überprüfe
das mache ich sehr gerne also bis dann
bleibt